vendredi les résultats du bac sont
tombés et dès le lendemain les nouveaux
laoréa ont pu participer au premier
forum logement de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin dans le hall
vaauan à cuillancour jeunes et parents
ont rencontré propriétaires et
organismes spécialisés comme le cru laad
78 procilia arpège ensemble de
génération la ville de Versailles ou les
résidences Adel mais pas facile de
trouver un logement pour Isaline dont
ses études dépendent directement de sa
capacité à trouver rapidement où habiter
la semaine dernière j'avais été à tour
car j'avais postulé également là-bas
j'étais accepté et j'ai eu un logement
et donc si jamais j'ai pas de logement
ici du coup je pense me réinscrire à
tour pour une licence droit langue
aujourd'hui les places dans le secteur
public sont rares seul 16 % des dossiers
reçus au crus aboutissent et même si
quatre nouvelles résidences doivent
ouvrir à la rentrée 2013 l'université
encourage ses étudiants vers des acteurs
privés comme Catherine arthu
propriétaire bailleur elle possède un 18
m² qu'elle loue 570 € par mois et un 34
m² à 660 € tout de meublés je viens de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui est très
intéressé et comme j'ai un autre
logement qui va certainement se se finir
pour la rentrée elle a euh deux petites
opportunités on a discuté ils viennent
visiter cet après-midi et il y a des
chances que que ça se fasse quoi
aujourd'hui l'université propose 1000
places d'hébergement à ces 18000
étudiants face à cette pénuie elle
n'hésite pas à prendre les devants
au niveau donc des garanties on a
plusieurs organismes qui s'occupent de
proposer des garanties donc pour les
propriétaire notamment le dispositif de
GRL garantie responsabilité locative
après le fait de louer à des étudiants
c'est c'est en général assz assez sûr
parce que l'université aussi derrière et
puis fait un contrôle des des demandant
200 personnes ont participé à ce premier
forum qui sera renouvelé l'année
prochaine